hi my name is markiplier welcome to pogo
stuck
i am upside down
but that's fine because i know how to
get through
this part here
that's how we do that's how we do that's
how we do oh
nada oh oh oh that's how we do oh my god
this out
where am i why there
no what
what why would that be
in any way that oh there's something to
be said about
perseverance in the face of adversity
there's many things that are gonna try
to get in your way in life and you
you can't always let them get you down
because sometimes
you can't exactly control no
oh my god was i saying somebody of
something inspirational
just uh uh i don't know lixian put
something really inspirational
right now here so that you know and then
make it seem like i said it
life will bring you down many times
but all that matters is how many times
you get back
up or something
oh my god why the control
of the jump power is just absurd it's
just as absurd
as any other part of this game like i i
get it now that i'm actually not just
completely relying on holding
sorry just thought of something really
funny there oh man
really funny stuff yeah i can't recite
the joke ndas and all that but
that was a really funny joke that just
took me here we go
nope not feeling that
ah god damn it i did it again it's the
same thing i
messed up on before
okay here and here and there and ah
frick crapping no god
no
god damn it i'm really incredibly
sad i'm rea oh man
oh man oh man i
am sad i'm big
sad sad i'm such big
sad i can't oh man i wish that joke came
back
i really loved the laugh of that joke
that i had
before but i can't remember it because
of all the
sad no
oh you tickle [ __ ]
no oh okay
again with the precision jump control it
is
so you know it's just so fine-tuned in
this game
oh yeah especially that no straight
through the
gap i say oh
what the what the what the hell
what the what yeah it's coming back to
me
the joke it's hilarious i remember
oh i remember now it's the funniest joke
that ever was told in the history of
forever
and it's getting less funny now and the
joke's going away
and uh you know i've laughed myself out
of it all
okay oh my god it doesn't matter what i
do
it's gonna do something else doesn't
matter what i do it doesn't matter how
many times i encounter the same problem
it gives me it's going to give me
something else
when i um that is just delightful
again what is the deal with the super
short
i don't understa oh what
god bless america
land that i love i would love to make
progress
okay
no oh my god oh my god no ah
grab it and go for it
yes this is how i do i'm back baby
and i know exactly how to beat you
i know the tricks i know the angles
i know it all you think i don't know you
think i've never faced
no don't do you cannot
do such things to me i'm immune
i'm immune to such trickery
no i don't understand you
yes yes
peace on earth no
peace on earth goodwill towards men
goodwill turns men why were you not
boost
now good ones
no no foreign no silly silly silly
you're being silly
no no no you're being silly stop no
my god oh my god oh my god no
jesus no no no no god
no what the freaking hell
what happened to what
oh my god
i'm immune who is
calling me right now who dares
call me right now go a thousand miles
away
oh my god it is such a fine angle
that angle fine [ __ ] dude
oh hi please go oh my god you [ __ ]
did it you distracted me
that is your only purpose
oh no where am i going
stop being you where am i going
i don't know i'm uh i [ __ ] went for
it
this is not gonna work no
i trying to get up to the flowers the
flowers are beautiful
and i want to be among them
yes yes yes yes
i am among the flowers this is where i
belong
these are my people well where do i go
from here i don't think i can climb this
can i oh [ __ ] oh shh i was among the
flowers
oh i was among i was among the flowers
no please
i was among the flowers i was among the
flowers
i was i was among the flowers i was i
was among the flowers
i i was among the flowers i was among
the flowers
i was among the flowers i i was among
the flowers i was among the flowers
where i belong where i was destined to
be i was among the flowers
i was i was among the flowers
i was among the flowers i was among the
flowers i was among the flowers
i was among the flowers i was among the
flowers
i was among the flowers
[Music]
no oh my god
oh my god
oh my god oh my god i was among the
flowers
yes i was among the flowers god every
time
every time i think i'm gonna get among
the flowers again
it just doesn't give it you oh my god
oh my god oh my god let me among the
flowers again
big flutter [ __ ] get out of here
yes no why was that not a boost
no why was that not a boost
why god damn it
why was that not a oh my god oh my god
why was that not a boost that was it
oh my god stop oh my god please stop
please stop
please why was that not a boost
why why was that not a boost why
why was that not a boost to jump i don't
understand
that should have been a boosted jump of
all the
i i play this game so much now
that i know when something's supposed to
be a
boost it's so weirdly inconsistent
oh there we go oh my god
oh my god i hate it so much i hate it
i hate it i hate it so much
it's always when it's right there god
when i need it to work
when i absolutely need to count on it
doing what i know it can do and it
i [ __ ] hate
this game right
right right right right
oh
oh
i am so sad
i'm just so sad guys
no god i didn't want to do that
no okay well you know what
why would i expect it to do what i want
to do why would i even assume that it
would
even think about my needs it would
always be
about the game's needs about what the
game wants and i
god damn it
just get me oh what is the slip
what is the slip what is the slip
it's the stupidest thing to slip the
little doinking oops
no what
that was absurd
oh no
oh no there i go
no oh and it
wow thank you that
oh thank you for that that's great
thank you thank you so much
oh you're not gonna you're not gonna
boost yeah that's that's the perfect
time to do that
i didn't need a boost or anything
okay what that was a
perfectly 90 degree wall bounce it's
always upside down
i think if if you look in the code
there's
there's code to make your pogo stickier
when you're upside down i thi it has to
be there is
no other way to explain that i was
perfectly
horizontal there's no other way to
explain
how that just happened other than if the
game developers
made it so that you're stickier when
you're upside down
they had to have because there's no
other explanation for it
there's no other behavior in this game
that is nearly as sticky
as being freaking upside down
which would be so like these developers
of this game
of who i don't know and i'm sure they're
fine people unless they're not
which which if they're not
then then oh my god
what no re really are you
kidding me no boost when i need the
boost
why why i don't
get it just be consistent that's all i
ask
that's all i've ever asked for games
that i play just be
consistent just be freaking
consistent and if you're not if you
can't be then
just stop pretending like you are
no no
oh my god i i'm
just no go oh
my goodness no don't punk you oh my god
no no no
i'm always so close to the next
threshold when i fail
oh my god i can do everything up until
that point perfectly and then i get to
the freaking
worst moment to possibly fail
and undoubtedly i do
oh freak you man freak you
so hard i can't
fathom why i've been chosen
to suffer i don't know what i
did what did i do what did i do what
what could i have possibly done to
deserve this
no every freaking no oh my god
what the frick oh my god
that's a new one i hate new ones
i hate new ways to fail that's not happy
no no i'm a broken man
i'm not who i once was and i don't
i don't think i ever will be again i
don't think i'll ever have another
chance
to redeem the person
that i was because he's dead no
he's dead long gone no
god i wish i could say
that the markiplier you knew would be
coming back but that would be a lie
oh oh my god
i'm so i'm so
freaking sick of this i am so
sick of this i am so sick
of being sent to the beginning i've got
182 degree
fever from being sent back to the
beginning
if you could stop sending me back
to the beginning that would be so nice
i am so sweaty i hate everything so much
there is only hate in my soul
only disdain in my heart
no boosts no problem i know how to beat
you
until you change the rules and you
always do you always change
what was that you changed the rules i
saw you just do it
you moved my character without the pogo
you moved it i saw it lixian slow it
down
and show the cheating that is rampant in
this game
it is not enough that the mechanic is
difficult
the programmers i know i know
they have programmed in ways to make it
inconsistently harder that is
indisputable at this point
because i have proof i have proof
they are
oh my god they are out to get me each
time i get closer
they change the rules just a little bit
more
just a little bit more so that it's like
oh maybe maybe i'm
maybe i'm crazy maybe i'm crazy maybe
they aren't changing the rules on me
maybe the game's just being what it is
and what it's always been
which is a little quirky and a little
funky but no
i know i know these things
oh god damn it
oh why why
um
oh wow
wow wow wow wow
that was more evidence
of this game cheating me oh my goodness
wow
oh wow i've got it on tape
you scum lords can't deny it anymore
you can't you can't deny it anymore
you can't deny it you're cheating me
you're
changing the game as i'm playing it
oh my god the developers they hacked
into my game
oh my god it's so clear now it's so
clear it's so hot
in my room it's so hot in my room
it's so hot in my room it's so warm
it's just been a heat wave and the air
conditioner doesn't work anymore
oh my god it's just not enough
oh
[Music]
it's so hot oh give me that
[Music]
i didn't pause i my hands were over here
i'm away from my controller
i didn't pause i didn't pause
they're here they're here
now they're controlling my game
[Music]
and they're here messing with me
but they won't beat me i belong among
the flowers
and i will be among the flowers
[Music]
oh oh
frick ah it hurts so bad
i can't describe its physical pain it's
physical pain
that's what i go through every time
you know some people they're cut out to
be like speed runners or
like power gamers or whatever have you
no
me not not one of those people
i oh
[Music]
wow
the slip i of all the things in this
game that i
[ __ ] hate it's the slip and
i don't like it it's it's if
if i could quantify it it's a bug and
it's just
it's just so frustrating because you
want to do something
fine-tuned small control that that that
those moves it's like you want to do
something fine controlled
and you you just get thwarted it's it's
like
it's like a system that's designed to
break what you're trying to do that's
all that does
oh god i was supposed to jump oh well
here i go
oh god why is that not when i need it to
be
when i absolutely need it to be a boost
it's not every time
i'm gonna be among the flowers no
no no no god every
every waking moment of my life is hell
every single
moment of my existence
is
please be gentle with me i'm such a soft
butterfly i deserve to be among the
flowers
i don't know if you know this it's true
ask anyone
i deserve to be among them oh
my god don't what are you doing
no oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god please do not
oh my god oh my god please
do what i need you to do
oh my god why why
what stop
stop
[Laughter]
thank you everybody so much for watching
i hope you enjoyed this video as much as
i did i hope you have a wonderful day
and everything goes your way and
everything loves you and
you have nothing but joy and happiness
in your heart you need to have that
i need that for you otherwise there was
no point i
wanted to rip my skin off and eat it
so that i can turn myself inside out
if you [ __ ] yawn at me again i will
rip your ears out and feed them to your
butthole
i need to go rip someone's ears out
there's a hungry butthole in the loose
leave a like
subscribe do it or i will
rip your ears off and i will feed them
to your butthole
time's up but whole time
can we use tears
[Music]
you